let's head back down to tampa and
camille kostik um
you got an exclusive somehow some way
with the gronkowski's including
the other woman in rob's life his mom
diane
yes kev this was finally my opportunity
to ask mama gronk
all the questions i've always wanted to
know
the one and only mrs g it'll be ring
number four i like to say when he wins
how do you think he's feeling is he
nervous i think he's
a little calmer because he's home so i
think that that helps a lot
diane is the mother to five gronk boys
rob was diane's baby number four
and she was the family's first mvp
corralling all that energy at home
so we know super bowl tough boy rob what
is he a mama's boy at the end of the day
yeah i'm giving away so many things mama
and no
i'm not giving away you because this is
my mama the fact that rob is a mama's
boy was on full display in this
instagram video promoting the family's
gronk nation super bowl giveaway for
fans all right
five boys who is your favorite
they all think that might they're my
favorite so to me is
whoever thinks they're the favorite
that's who the favorite is
camille also got a chance to explore the
gronk family bro code with rob's
brothers
gordy chris dan and glenn so we're gonna
play a game called
wood gronk rather would rob
rather double date with thomas gisele or
with one of his brothers and their
significant others
wow i'm saying with his bros i would say
with the bros too
i gotta say tommy yeah yeah
okay would gronk rather be late for
date night or be late for football
practice
oh date night date night all day no good
fine
big bucks much
now you may have noticed that our
jerseys are red and that is in support
of the
american heart association's go red for
women national wear red day yes we have
got to take care of this ladies let's be
heart healthy and
let's check back with camille one last
time miss camille we have got pom-poms
and spirit fingers all over the place
i love it now i'm with the tampa bay
buccaneer cheerleaders who are you
rooting for
let's go go box back to you guys
wait did i hear a go bucks i do have my
missouri necklace on today i just have
to counter
i it's just a counterpoint homer homer
by the way make sure you join us on
monday for all of our super bowl
coverage yeah it's going to be amazing
we are going to be coming to you from
sofi
stadium the home of the rams and the
chargers and next year's super bowl
it's going to be an amazing show
you